le début aujourd'hui de la semaine
fraich'attitude une opération du
ministre de l'agriculture et des
professionnels pour relancer la
consommation des fruits et légumes
des animations sont organisées un peu
partout en france la consommation des
fruits et légumes qui n'arrive pas à
décoller malgré les nombreuses campagnes
d'information sur leurs bienfaits pour
la santé
sophie guillemin est égale haendel une
barquette de fruits frais offertes
gratuitement à la sortie du métro pour
certains parisiens la journée a plutôt
bien commencé ce matin objectif de la
distribution fait redécouvrir le plaisir
de déguster des produits frais mais
aussi convaincre depuis 20 ans près de
300 études ont permis de démontrer que
consommer cinq fruits et légumes par
jour réduisait considérablement le
risque de développer certaines maladies
et que rien ne pouvait encore remplacer
ces aliments
malgré les très nombreux travaux
scientifiques y ont lieu on ne sait pas
qu'elle est composée exact il ya
l'intérieur des fruits et légumes
explique cet effet protecteur vis-à-vis
des maladies certaines vitamines les
fibres décomposé comme les polyphénols
ont sûrement un rôle mais on n'est pas
capable d'identifier quelles molécules
spécifiques et c'est pour cela que les
programmes de santé publique comme le
programme national nutrition santé
recommande de consommer les fruits et
légumes en nature c'est à dire vraiment
pas sous forme de compléments
alimentaires ou de suppléments mais sous
forme d'aliments pour que le message
passe
les spécialistes sont unanimes il faut
s'y prendre très tôt
ici des élèves scolarisés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire sont invités à
découvrir des produits que bien souvent
ils n'ont pas l'habitude de manger on
aperçoit la ville de nantes
chose non n'est pas quelque chose de
on va dire d'aller comme un coureur
parce que vous
le prix des légumes des fruits secs pour
la population la haie
donc c'est une chance pour eux de
découvrir des fruits nouveau des légumes
nouveaux et
réapprendre à manger dans les écoles les
hôpitaux les entreprises près de 15000
opération de sensibilisation aux
bienfaits des fruits et des légumes sont
organisées jusqu'au 28 mai